recently moved up and was promoted and
not liking it because I have to adjust
massively is there a difference between
liking your job and lack of discipline
to perform a change are there are they
connected yeah well they're definitely
connected it's a tough one the first
thing I would say is that if it was a
real radical change you know it takes
people unless they're very young it
takes people about a year to adjust to a
really radical change like to move to a
new city to to adjust to being married
that can take longer than a year to
adjust to having a new baby to to
getting over of relatively serious loss
like a death in the family a year you
know and so the first thing you might
ask yourself is are there things that
are good about the promotion
the second is do you have the capacity
to do the job or to learn how to do it
you could talk to someone about that and
then the third thing is have you given
yourself enough time to adjust because
one of the things I often recommend to
people when they've made a radical
change like going leaving home and going
to university is don't pay any attention
to how you feel for a year because
everything is so much up in the air that
you can't really trust your own judgment
so you have to give yourself time to
adapt and you can't expect that that's
going to happen overnight it's certainly
not and to put that expectation on
yourself increases the probability that
you're going to feel bad about it